name these new ryzen 6000 series with
nvidia graphics finally match up to the
m2 chip in this m2 macbook air well
today we will find out because we have
this brand new lenovo laptop that not
only is priced lower than apples but
also gives you a lot more value so we're
also going to compare the displays the
keyboards the speakers and webcams along
with real world performance to see which
one of these machines is the better one
and if windows actually has some great
competition and i'm super excited to
check it out now let's start out with
the actual designs this lenovo it's
classy it's kind of old school but they
added some modern touches it's really
interesting how the macbook is all flat
now where's this lenovo went to a nice
round style kind of bubbly right there
at the end and a little bit tapered now
we also have a lot more buttons and
ports we have a usb over here headphone
jack a power button here and then we
literally have a switch which turns off
the webcam and on the other side we have
another usba port and two usb type cs
which brings me to thunderbolt because
this is an amd laptop it doesn't have it
so the macbooks two thunderbolt ports
can actually have four times the data
and of course the macbook now has max
save so you don't have to use one of the
usbc ports to charge like you do on the
lenovo with that the lenovo is a fair
bit thicker not only on the back but
even on the front where it tapers and
it's also significantly heavier as well
coming in at 3.5 pounds compared to 2.7
and that is noticeable honestly it seems
to be more of a competitor to the
14-inch macbook pro but because of that
price point it falls in line with the
air getting into the inside one awesome
thing is the facial recognition with
windows hello and this thing has a ton
of sensors
which means it can look at depth so
it'll be more secure and i wish we had
that with the m2 macbook air but we just
have touch id now lenovo is known for
their nice keyboards and the keys
themselves do feel nice but i'm not a
fan of how small the actual keycaps are
the macbook airs keys are wider and i
prefer them overall and the same thing
goes for the track pad this magnetic one
is fantastic whereas the lenovo it is
still using a diving board design that
isn't bad but it's definitely not great
now what about the speakers apple got
rid of the speaker grills they put the
speakers right over here bouncing off
the display instead of a firing so let's
go ahead and compare them
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well that was a disappointment the empty
macbook air got quieter this year uh
it's not as
wide as stereo sound but it still
destroys the speakers that in this
larger and heavier lenovo now as far as
the webcams both of them are 1080p but
there could be a lot of differences so
here is the m2 macbook airs webcam and
the microphone and here is lenovo's
1080p webcam and their microphones you
guys let me know which one looks better
and which one sounds better down in the
comments section below as for displays
apple calls theirs a 14 inch just like
lenovo but this is a 13.6 compared to a
14.5 so it is slightly larger now as far
as the resolution i was surprised that
this is a 3k display that is a perfect
balance between sharpness and battery
life compared to apples which is close
to that 2.5 now the kicker is that this
display can support 120 hertz now it's
not enabled out of the box because it
uses a lot more battery it's not the
same as pro motion that can slow itself
down but it is nice to have and with
that this is a touch screen as well so
uh you can just move stuff around you
can scroll which apple obviously doesn't
do that now the lenovo isn't as bright
coming in at 400 nits compared to 500
and with that it's a lot more reflective
as well which is a bummer and that's
probably because of the touchscreen
layer so using it outside might be a bit
tough and the same thing when you're
watching videos the blacks look great
because that touchscreen layer compared
to a much deeper black here and
highlights also pop a lot more lenovo
says that the display is factory
calibrated but a lot of the colors just
seem kind of muted
so i would say probably for accuracy
it's better to go with the macbook
better contrast but of course this has
its benefits as well and now let's see
what this thing could do getting into
performance the first thing i want to
test is the ssd speed not only do we
have one terabyte instead of 512 over
here but it's also pci gen 4 ssds now
looking at the actual speed it does not
look like gen 4 performance even though
they're advertising it so maybe the
connection is gen 4 but the ssd's
actually not that fast the macbook's a
little bit slower and right but as far
as the read it is faster i was genuinely
not expecting that but i guess you are
getting a whole terabyte now i'm really
curious about the web browsing
performance with this new amd
6000 series it's a lot better and i'm
using chrome on both to make it fair we
have a score of 204 which is not bad and
it is on battery right now compared to
353 which is insanely good nothing else
can match up so for web-based
applications google drive docs the
macbook is the winner and now let's push
the processors here we have a ryzen 6800
hs creator edition which has a cores 16
threads up to 4.7 gigahertz compared to
an 8 core but only 4 are fast with the
m2 going up to 3.5 alright and the
performance is in and you guys have to
see this we have
6017
multi-core score compared to 8961
that is crazy now single core also a
massive massive difference now we are in
battery power right this has a large
battery and we do have it set to maximum
performance we checked all the other
power settings everything's maxed out
it's in extreme mode we still have a 50
difference in multi-core that is crazy
now with that we have 75 percent of
battery life remaining four hours or so
whereas on the macbook we're still at 92
and we haven't been doing things that
are that tough yet so let's go ahead and
plug this thing in since it obviously
needs to be plugged in to get the full
performance which is one thing that
frustrates me about a lot of windows
laptops and let's see what it could do
all right there we go we have 8893
much better but still slightly behind
the m2 macbook air and as far as single
core it is also faster but it's still
about 28
slower so uh the macbook is competing
now of course this is a fanless machine
so let's go ahead and test out something
that's going to push these a little bit
harder now we're starting cinebench r23
and i want to see one how hot does this
thing get and how much power does it use
dang
65
watts
with this amd
processor okay that is insane and so far
it's still running there alright i spoke
too soon 54 starting to slow down the m2
air hit a peak of 23 compared to 65 and
now it's running at 20 compared to 54 or
so now of course this thing is heating
up the m2 macbook air is fanless it's
hot we're here the fans turned on almost
instantly but it's keeping up that power
so i'm very curious what we get we're
almost done here and it's crazy
how hot this thing is 49.50 at the
hottest points here compared to the
macbook the hottest point is 47
and that this thing is still running at
54 watts
after all this time the empty air is now
only using 12.5 watts
because it's throttled down it's ran too
hot and now the only thing you do is
slow down now we did show off what we
used a laptop cooler and some thermal
pads and maintain performance uh way
better and consistently and look at that
difference
we have
7958 on the macbook all right that's
decent not bad it did slow down but 11
807
with this amd processor plugged in that
is 48
more powerful for this extended task now
if we went longer uh then the macbook
would slow down to about 7 300 and then
using our cooler it would stay about 8
350 still no comparison now what i'm
curious about is
how is this going to compare when it
comes down to real world tasks now as
far as graphics performance we have the
nvidia rtx 3050 gpu and the lenovo
versus the bend acor graphics in the m2
macbook air and look at that the nvidia
graphics are more than twice as powerful
as the apple ones and then i ran it
again unplugged and it did go down uh
just a tiny bit pretty much twice the
performance that's great that doesn't
slow down let's put those graphics to
use with blender this is one area where
the nvidia graphics are really great at
especially with opt-x rendering dang
this thing is smoking it we have 12
seconds remaining here compared to 2
minutes all right that was 26 seconds
for the lenovo and 2 minutes and 16
seconds for our macbook air now why in
the world is it so fast well because
optix uses the ray tracing cores in the
nvidia graphics and it makes it
extremely fast so if you want to work
with 3d graphics you should definitely
get a nvidia laptop now on the flip side
for video editing i have a standard 4k
project open right here with some luts
some film grain and both these laptops
are handling it perfectly now the lenovo
is running its fans it's not maxed out
like in cinebench uh but maybe 50
playing this back and people talk about
how the macbooks have great media
engines and that's why it's so fast but
nvidia has excellent ones themselves and
now let's go ahead and export this five
minute project our lenovo is encoding at
about 54 frames per second compared to
about
78.80 on the macbook air running
silently of course and without the power
cable plugged in the mac took a minute
and 32 seconds compared to 2 minutes and
14 seconds
now that is still a killer speed and
performance for this lenovo if it had
intel integrated graphics it would be
six seven minutes so that is great but
it's still fifty percent slower now just
like in blender where the lenovo can use
the ray tracing cores apple added prores
decoders and encoders to the m2 macbook
so playing back these prores files the
macbook barely has to use any power
compared to using a lot of cpu and
graphics that also means they can fly
through prores footage and even work
with prores raw in final cut taking just
36 seconds in order to encode this five
minute project so for most video
creators working with 4k footage uh
maybe prores and compressed the macbook
even the air is the way to go but what
about photography this is an area where
it's going to use the cpu and the
graphics i have the latest version of
photoshop opened up on both and i'm
going to go ahead and do a photo merge
with a bunch of images our macbook's not
really using that much of the cpu and
the graphics i wonder how much the
neural engine is helping it out wow okay
the macbook is done we can just crop in
after that the lenovo is running its
fans pretty loud because it's using a
lot of that raw performance that is
higher than the macbook air but the
macbook air stayed really cool because
of that extra help and that knurl engine
alright it is done that took three
minutes and two seconds
compared to one minute and 52 seconds so
not twice as fast but it's getting
closer to that and honestly that is
something that i was not expecting just
because the graphics are faster the cpu
is faster and we're plugged in compared
to unplugged and now we are in lightroom
classic which is great when you have a
lot of photos to edit i have 50 42
megapixel edited images and as i switch
them they have to apply all those
effects this uses the graphics and the
processor
and it's interesting that each time i
flip through
the macbook is faster
every single time now we know that ssds
these are pci express 4 they're fairly
close but most of this just graphics
based because the images are about 40
megabytes a piece i'm honestly
surprised by this because it's not using
any encoders or anything like that and
now let's go ahead and export these 50
images wow this is unreal the macbook is
flying
i know unified memory also helps not
that it's a cheat but it's just more
efficient everything being together and
it is almost done here so it looks like
with the windows laptop both the cpu and
the graphics are being used i did enable
full graphics acceleration
but it's taking turns the cpu will kick
up then it'll send off
the processing to the graphics so the
cpu slows down
back to the cpu for each image whereas
the macbook it shares all the data all
right guys it is finished that took two
minutes and two seconds which is still
not bad compared to a minute and 12
seconds so almost twice as fast for the
mac showing off just how good having
that unified apple silicon with the
memory there just the efficiency we have
the raw performance in cinebench and in
geekbench metal for graphics but when it
comes together well you guys see the
difference there so overall well what
did we learn yes it's a great price you
do get a terabyte and you get 16 gigs of
ram still a bit less expensive but the
ssd isn't a pci express four speeds like
we've seen with adele and with that even
though in blender nvidia graphics are
amazing for pretty much everything else
even the fanless macbook air does a much
better job speakers
you guys let me know about the webcam it
is really impressive so there you guys
go if you like windows it's still a
great laptop for a great price has a lot
of performance and for gaming it'll be
great but as an overall machine this is
why a lot of people are switching over
from windows to macbooks ever since
apple silicon came out so thank you guys
for watching go ahead and click that
circle above to subscribe check out one
of those great videos right over there
this one max and i'll see you in the
next video
[Music]